From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
The way that I like to work if it's okay with you is I work pretty chronologically.
I always think that the work that people end up doing in their lives is always shaped by their families
and where they come from and the communities and what they raised and all of that.
So I take a pretty, you know, traditional family history approach, at least to where we start.
That sounds good.
Great. And then, and certainly in your case, there's, I don't know, there'll be a lot of rich, relevant memories that pertinent to this ill-orice movement.
We'll talk about other things as well.
And then, and then carry on through your life into your, your own career and where you see these themes sort of playing out.
Okay.
If that sounds good to you.
Sounds good.
It's really, it's your interview, you're in charge, you want to take a break at any point.
If you want to take it in a completely different direction, it's up to you.
We're very informal in that way.
Okay.
And we would really want you to be in charge of where we go.
Sounds good.
I also try to keep us all on track.
Yeah, we usually go.
They vary from 40 minutes, 45 minutes or so to two hours.
But, you know, as much time as you want to give us.
And I think we're good for time in terms of our flight and all of that.
Okay.
Great.
What I'll do first is just record a little opening message for the file so that we know where we were and when.
And then we'll start having a conversation.
Sounds good.
Thank you.
Oh, with all of that.
Okay.
Great.
So today is August 17, 2013.
We are in Richmond, Virginia.
My name is David Klein from the Department of History at Virginia Tech in Blacksburg.
Also working with the Southern oral history program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
We are here today for the Civil Rights History Project with the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Behind the camera is John Bishop from Media Generation and UCLA.
And we are very pleased to be here today with all of our W. Hill junior in Richmond and good morning.
Good morning.
And thank you so much for being part of this project.
I'm pleasure.
Okay.
Great. Thank you.
So what we'll do is we'll just start by talking a bit about your childhood and your family.
Okay.
And then we'll have a good conversation going forward.
So you could tell us when you were born and where and a little bit about the community in which you were raised.
Okay.
I was born in 1949 in Richmond, Virginia.
And of course in those days, Richmond was a very segregated community.
So I was born in the Black Hospital, which now is a dorm at Virginia Union University.
And in those days, the Black community was its own circumscribed world.
I mean, you really didn't have to go outside of it if you didn't want to.
The pharmacy was down the street in the restaurants.
We had the same neighborhood and you kind of circled in that neighborhood.
And that was kind of the hub of my life for the first 12 years or so that that was alive.
Were there certain six years within that community?
Certain people who had that were sort of heads of the community or certain businesses that were the center of life?
I mean, one of the things that was interesting was that the neighborhoods were very heterogeneous.
You know, you would have a lawyer next to a construction worker, next to a plumber.
So in terms of class, you had much more integration than you do today.
And again, because there were so many restrictions on where you could go and where you couldn't go,
you know, there were industries and commercial organizations to take care of whatever needs you had in the community.
So in those, in that sense, it was a very self-contained kind of community.
And my family was a typical in one sense of that.
My father was a civil rights attorney and so he was traveling a lot.
And he was involved with cases from the NAACP Legal Defense Fund.
We, as a result, we would have a lot of threats coming in over the telephone.
And so I wasn't allowed to answer the phone for a long time in the evenings.
We even had a cross-brandon I got at one time.
Do you remember that?
Yeah, I was probably about six or seven, you know, it was exciting.
I mean, my parents had consciously tried to kind of build up my sense of self.
And so that I would be shielded a little bit from the racism and the kinds of reprisals and repercussions that were coming from my father's work.
And also, I think they also figured that I was going to be in the group that desegregated schools in Richmond.
And I was.
So there was an attempt to try to inculcate in me the idea that prejudice was somebody else's problem.
It was an indication of their pathology, not my pathology.
And that worked to a certain extent.
Although I'm looking back on growing up in the 50s, I mean, the all white world that you have seen on the television and the media definitely had an effect on me.
I mean, when I would color in a coloring book, I would never think about coloring somebody skinned brown.
Because the norm was white.
You know, I wanted wavy hair like Elvis Presley.
So those kinds of marks were definitely there.
But I did have a good sense of self and my parents had done a good job in protecting me on that level.
Well, you mentioned Elvis Presley and those kinds of things that were happening psychologically.
Did you have other heroes as a kid?
Well, I mean, most of the heroes that I was exposed to in TV and comic books and things were white.
So I was kind of a typical kid on that level.
They really wasn't a real push for black history at that time.
So I really hadn't been exposed to a lot of black heroes.
Although my parents had always talked to me about heroes of the black experience.
There wasn't a lot of written material on that.
They would tell me about it and conversations around it in the table.
And I was the only child.
So they did include me in their discussions, you know, for the most part, about issues of segregation and politics and anything else that might be happening around that time.
Could you tell us a little bit more about who your parents were,
what their backgrounds were, and how they came to be doing that work?
My father was also born in Richmond in 1907.
And early on he moved to Ronoke.
His father kind of deserted the family early on.
So he was being raised by his mother.
And in Ronoke she would go for seasonal work up to places like,
what's the name of the resort hotel's out there drawing a blank home stead and the green bride.
And so he was kind of put in this foster home of this middle class family in Ronoke who did a lot of raising of him during those early years.
Name the Pentecost.
And Mr. Black family.
But Mr. Pentecost was a very, I don't know, well read, well spoken, very stern kind of person who worked on the railroads.
And my father was, you know, kind of living in that environment.
I think that had a big influence on his early years.
And my grandmother remarried and eventually moved to Washington with her new husband.
And so my father stayed in Ronoke until he was ready to enter high school because at that time there were no black high schools in Ronoke.
None.
So he then went to Washington for high school.
And he went to a high school named Dunbar, which was very prestigious high school in those days.
It was said to have more PhDs on the high school faculty than some of the colleges in the area.
Which is actually not a typical of black schools in the era.
Right.
It's true.
So he had a great experience at Dunbar and kind of got his academic footing.
But he was still kind of a devil-may-care type personality.
But he decided he was going to go to college.
And before that, his, one of his uncles had worked in a law office and gave him a copy of an annotated constitution.
And he said in reading that he couldn't understand why segregation laws were constitutional.
And this is really what inspired him to go into law school.
So there was a convergence of things happening at that time at Howard in the late 1920s.
There was a president there, Mordekar Johnson, who was interested in producing a type flight law school.
At that time, Howard's law school was just a night school.
But he brought in a dean from, who had just got his PhD in law from Harvard, named Charles Hamlin Houston.
And so Mordekar Johnson and Houston kind of molded the faculty in the organization of this law school.
And so Howard also had a program where you could do three years of undergraduate and then go to law school and get your bachelor's degree after the first year in law school.
This is my father took advantage of that.
And one of his classmates was Thurgood Marshall, who had been turned down from going to University of Maryland law school.
So he was there for that reason.
And they said the first day in class, Charles Hamlin Houston told him that, you know, as lawyers, you're either a social parasite or you're a social engineer.
And he was determined they were going to become social engineers.
And from that very first year in that first class, Charles Hamlin Houston was kind of guiding the strategy of attacking segregation, mainly in the form of a Plessy versus Ferguson, which was a Supreme Court case that established separate but equal.
My father tells the story that in that time when he was in college in the 1920s, you couldn't even get a law passed against lynching because of the power of the Southern block in Congress.
And so that was one of the things that convinced him that it would take something going to the Supreme Court to make a real change.
And so that was part of his motivation as well.
So when he got out of law school in 1933, he went back to Rono to start to practice.
But this was middle of depression. And he was having a hard time making an living. So he started waiting tables to earn money.
But at the same time, and I can't remember the name of the person, but there was a white individual from a wealthy family who gave a large donation to the NAACP was used to kind of
bankroll the NAACP Legal Defense Fund. And so Charles Hamlin Houston and Thurby Marshall and my father and several other lawyers were working with NAACP Legal Defense Fund and starting to look for these cases to gradually assault segregation.
So did the NAACP they called on your father to get going?
Well, I mean, there was this close circle of black looks, almost all of them were Howard graduates. So they all knew each other. And so they all continued to work together.
So Howard really, the Howard Law School under Houston, I mean, that was one of these key places in your opinion where the F-L-A-L-L-L-L-L-F fired up the movement.
And it was a conscious effort on the part of Houston and Mordekar Johnson to do this. So in the 1930s, one of the first big cases that they had some success with was the school salary case.
I mean, the teacher salary case in Virginia. And those days, the highest pay, black teacher had to make less than the lowest pay, why teach it.
So that was kind of an easy case to take. Although it took several years before it was filing resolved and it was in the 1940s, I think it was filing resolved.
But my father, you know, started working in Virginia and by this time he had moved back to Richmond.
And then he was in his 40s, but he got drafted for World War II. And he thinks it was kind of a conscious decision about the local draft boy.
He's trying to get him out of their hair. But once he got in the army, he got to the level of sergeant. He kept pressing for them to send him to Officer Training School as a lawyer.
And they would usually transfer him somewhere else before they got to that point.
So yeah, here's this guy with a law degree and they're not taking advantage of that at all.
And even in England, he was, again, kicking up a fuss about getting to Officer Canada's school. And that actually caused his unit to be a little bit late.
And otherwise, he probably would have been in D-Day, but his unit came up a little bit later.
And he was serving in an all-black unit?
Yes, in England.
Right. And then into France.
Then when he came back from the war, he started getting involved with local politics here in Richmond.
He was one of the first blacks. I guess he was the first black to be elected to an office in the deep south since reconstruction.
He was elected to the Richmond City Council.
Do you remember anything about that campaign?
Well, that was before I was born.
But he did have several other campaigns after I was born and I do remember those.
He ran for House of delegates and lost by 40 votes, I think, or some really close race in the early 50s.
But he was always involved in the Virginia Democratic Party.
And even when he was running for City Council, he didn't just confine his race to the black community.
He would go around to white communities, knock on doors and ask them for their vote.
So he was always kind of fearless in that way.
And he always attended every meeting, any kind of political thing that was going on in Richmond, it didn't matter whether it was conservative or liberal.
He would be there, if I was in his opinion.
And of course, all this time they were continuing with this strategy of overturning Plessy.
And they finally found some cases that they thought were going to be the ones they needed, particularly the Clarence and County case in South Carolina.
And it was around that time that he got a call from Barbara Johns in Farmville.
And of course, they were planning to have this boycott of a walk out of their school because of the conditions.
And just for the record, for those who don't or are new to this history, could you tell us a little bit about who Barbara Johns was and what was going on in Farmville?
Yeah, well, Barbara Johns was a high school girl.
And the black high school in Farmville was a really bad condition.
And I think they were, you know, in some kind of tar paper shacks out in the back for some of the overflow and rain would come in.
And they would have dripping water on their desks.
Anyway, Barbara Johns kind of organized the students to come up with a protest.
And they were going to have a walk out and refuse to go back until the conditions had changed.
And she called my father to come and represent them because the school board was, you know, upset about all this.
And their parents were upset because, you know, they were kind of in precarious positions.
And at this time, my father, you know, they kind of had their plates full, particularly, and they thought they had all the cases they needed for this push to the Supreme Court.
But Barbara Johns was so persistent and so organized that he just couldn't resist him.
So they decided to come at least visit Farmville and talk to the parents.
And by this time, they had started to change their strategy.
When they first started attacking segregation, they were on the basis of separate but equal.
And no southern state had the resources to have completely equal educational facilities for the black kids.
And so that was the vulnerable point.
But by this time, they decided they were going to change the strategy and start to attack segregation per se.
So in Farmville, that was one of the things he told the parents.
Because the children organized this community meeting with parents and everybody for the lawyers to come in and talk.
And one of the things he said was, you know, this is about desegregation per se, not just about separate but equal.
And kind of let them know what they would be in for.
Be a relatively long fight.
But the community was ready to support it.
So that case, Davis versus Prince Edward County, became one of the cases that was part of the Brown package.
I guess it was alphabetical who was Brown, but where Brown gets the styling with.
Okay.
So that was the Farmville.
Farmville, yes.
And then went on for quite some time.
Well, this was I think 52 in Barbara Johns first called him and it was 54 before the case was finally decided by the Supreme Court.
Well, that time Barbara Johns suffered a lot.
She eventually had to leave Farmville because of the pressures that were mounting against her.
She comes from an interesting family to her father was Reverend, I can't remember his first name, Andy.
Vernon Johns.
Was her uncle.
Vernon Johns was her uncle.
Yeah, the father's name I don't remember either.
And Vernon Johns who was in Petersburg for a while eventually went down to Alabama and he was at the church right before Martin Luther King came out of connections to Virginia to this early civil rights activity.
Although most people think the civil rights movement started in the 1950s, but you know, 30 years before they were starting these cases in the court.
In fact, 10 years before Rosa Parks, my father's firm had a case with Irene Morgan who was the same kind of story she refused to give a proceed on a bus.
This was the interstate bus and eventually that case led to interstate segregation, interstate transportation being ruled illegal.
Okay.
So, yeah, there were a lot of precursors to Martin Luther King in the 50s.
And then the interstate travel law was one that they used testing that to push into the stuff.
With the freedom rights.
Yeah.
Very interesting.
So did you get the sense from your father that he had a sense of this being incremental one step at a time kind of a...
Yeah, for sure.
And you know, from the time he left law school to the brown decision that was almost 20 some years.
So they did see this as this incremental strategy.
And again, changing strategy because they started out with attacking separate equal and then eventually attacking segregation itself.
And it was interesting because in those days because Richmond was segregated when the lawyers would come through town they would always stay with us because they couldn't stay in the hotels downtown.
There were a few black hotels around like Eglistan's and slaughters but they usually tend to stay with us.
So there would be these little strategies, sessions around the breakfast table and I would be off in the corner somewhere.
I didn't know exactly what was going on but I just knew something important was happening.
And you know, they're good Marshall and Bob Carter and some of the other lawyers would always be through town.
So it was an interesting time.
And your father's partner was Spotswood Robinson.
Spotswood Robinson, right?
And when did they start working together?
Well, they started in the 40s and they continued to be partners through the 50s and then...
Spotswood Robinson went to Howard to be the dean of the law school and eventually a federal judge.
One of the things that was interesting was that all the lawyers for the NAACP thought that once the Supreme Court made this decision that would be it, that would be the law of the land, everybody would comply.
The country would be changed.
And of course Virginia led the push for massive resistance and to resist the desegregation order and who knows what kind of effect that had on the country.
We probably could be in the post-racial society now maybe if that law had been complied with.
But can you talk about some of the actual responses from the White community that made our massive resistance?
Well, we're led by members of the Bird Machine in Virginia. The governor at the time was Jaylen Zalman.
So it was at the highest level that this resistance was coming.
And you know, this was kind of unheard of that the governor and state legislatures were going to just defy the law.
And so a whole new set of cases had to start to be put together to try to force compliance.
And so I guess for the next 10 years or so, that was the nature of the cases.
I was in one of the first group of students in Virginia to desegregate the schools until the 1960s.
So that was like seven years after the Brown decision.
And for most of Virginia, desegregation didn't come for another five or six years.
So even here in Richmond, what level school was it that you were in?
I was in junior high school at the time.
And it was a court case that was brought?
Well, this was, it wasn't a specific case, but this was a continual fight that they had.
At those days, they had something called a pupil placement board.
And a pupil placement board would decide what schools you would go to.
And it was interesting though that head of the school board at that time was Louis Powell, who was a fairly progressive individual.
He and my father had a really good relationship.
And so he would always give my father an opportunity to speak before the school board and before other community groups.
So, you know, there was a gradual trickle of black students that were starting to be allowed into the white schools.
But it was definitely not integration.
And my father would say it was desegregation, but not integration.
It's just a token number of students.
Can you tell us a little bit about what that difference is?
Well, as you saw it as you saw it.
As he saw it was mainly in terms of numbers.
If he had two black kids in a high school of 1,500, he wouldn't say that was an integrated school.
It might be desegregated, but it's not integrated.
Because I'm also, right now I'm looking at the military during the Korean War.
And it's the same thing when you say integrate the services and send a single black soldier to a white unit is that what is that?
Yeah, yeah.
But, you know, the military probably was one of the most progressive institutions in terms of eventual integration.
Once the presidential directive was given.
But so that was your own case.
So, your own experience?
Yeah.
So, you know, I really didn't want to be one of these students who was integrating.
So, I wanted to go to the black schools with all my friends.
You know, it was interesting that it was inevitable based on what my father was doing.
But they would do such ridiculous things as take out yardsticks and measure the distance from one school to another to try to keep kids out.
I can remember one friend of mine who wasn't allowed in Chandler, which was the white junior high school.
Because, Grey's, which was the black school, was three feet closer to his house than Chandler.
So, there's a lot of that kind of stuff going on.
But eventually, you know, we did start to trickle in.
And so, I can remember the first day of going to the white junior high school.
And my father had been working in the Kennedy campaign and he got a job, but was given a job at the Federal Housing Administration during the Kennedy Administration.
So, he was in Washington most of the week these days.
And I remember the first day of school I was given a ride with his new junior partner, Henry Marsh, gave me a ride to school that morning.
And I was walking up the steps. It was like the school was deserted out in front.
There was nobody, no teachers, no movement, no nothing. It was me walking up these steps.
And then I went to the principal's office and there were other black kids there in the principal's office.
And then they marched this out two by two to the different home rooms.
You know, they kind of had this partial doubt around the school.
So, it was kind of an interesting, surrealistic day.
And...
Did no big backlash on that day?
No big backlash on that day.
You know, after a while, you started to sort things out. And you would know the kids in the areas where you would tend to get call NIGA or some other problem would happen.
And you would tend to avoid those situations as much as possible.
And of course the black kids mainly kept together.
But over the years, gradually people started to get to know one another.
And then when I was in the middle of the class, it was in the seventh grade then, kind of went all the way through high school.
And by the time I got to high school, I was on the football team.
And so, you know, the real problem kids were also on the football team.
And so you kind of got to know them when they got to be teammates.
And it was kind of like, you know, the way in which people envision integration working.
And you go together, you kind of acknowledge the humanity that you share.
And even those who were most prejudiced at the seventh grade, were gradually, you know, starting to become at least friendly.
If not friends.
By the time we got to high school.
So changing minds one person at a time.
Yeah.
But of course, you had to take on when you're a teenager.
Yeah, it is.
And by the time I got to high school, well, maybe a year or two after I left high school, it was a black girl who was the prom queen in that same school.
So there really was, starting to be kind of even a little bit of a social integration in schools.
When I was there, it was pretty still much social segregation.
I mean, we ate together in the cafeteria.
If we went to a dance at the high school, we would have our area.
We would be dancing and they would have their area.
But gradually, that started to change.
But of course, as soon as things started to gradually integrate, then you had to re-saggregation with the right flight with the busing that came in the late 1960s.
So, you know, had the experiment continued, you know, again, things might be a little different now.
And Richmond did experience a lot of that white flight.
Oh, yeah. Once the busing was instituted as a remedy.
And one other courageous figure at that time was Judge Robert Marriage, who was a local judge here in Richmond who ordered busing patterns that included the surrounding counties.
And I mean, just to show how these little circumstances led to some really important ramifications.
That solution, you know, would have really had a big impact.
We still have this tension between the city and the counties today.
I mean, kind of a leftover from those old racial politics days.
But Marriage was, you know, he also got a lot of threats.
The dog was killed.
You know, his children were threatened.
And when the case went to, I don't know what circuit it was, but it was overturned.
And then it went to the Supreme Court.
And the Supreme Court then Nixon had just nominated the former Chief Justice.
So, who was his name?
I'm in a senior moment here.
A rinkwist.
And also he had tried to nominate Harold Carzwell, but that didn't, that was blocked by the Senate.
And so he nominated Lewis Powell.
And Lewis Powell and Rinkwist got on the bench.
They hadn't heard the original arguments for this case.
And Powell, because of his previous association with the Richmond School,
what recused himself.
And Rinkwist didn't.
And so the Supreme Court had a 4-4 split, which meant that the lower court finding was upheld.
And so the inclusion of the counties in the busing plan, you know, fell through.
But Powell not recused himself or had Rinkwist recused himself.
This might be a different world now.
But anyway, you know-
I've done some work in Louisville, which is interesting because they just, at the same time that they passed busing,
they collapsed, they just collapsed County and city government into one.
Yeah.
There's one way to get around that.
Because Richmond is really interesting in the way racial politics works.
At first, once in the late 60s and early 70s, when you did have this white flight,
of course, now you had much more black political power in Richmond.
And so the white political structure in Richmond started to annex territory from the surrounding counties.
And that was eventually blocked by the federal government based on the Voting Rights Act, because it was an attempt to dilute the black, the strengths of the black vote.
So they couldn't annex anymore.
So now, you had continued white flight.
And now the legislature, once blacks got in power in Richmond, passed the law that Richmond couldn't no longer annex any territory.
So as land locked, all the tax base was moving out to the counties.
And this is a pattern that you see over and over again in cities.
But Richmond in Virginia is unique, and usually you do have cities embedded in a county.
But in Richmond, you have these independent cities.
And so, you know, even to this day, the same struggles between the counties and the cities are there.
Now it's clothed more in class kinds of issues.
The race issue morphed into a class issue, because you had a lot of black flight too, black middle class flight.
But in your opinion, the race issue is still embedded in there?
Oh, it's still in there, yeah. But it's kind of tamped down.
I mean, close the door.
We'll back.
Or you mentioned this a little bit, but were you a little bit miffed at your dad that are your folks that you were put forth as an experimenter?
I was a little bit miffed, but I kind of recognized that the cause was good.
And, you know, I still had a lot of social connections to the kids going to the black schools, because that was still our social group.
How did you get to school?
Yeah, I mean, you talked about the first day, but how did you get to school during the rest of your career?
Most of the time I walked. It really wasn't a Chandler.
We lived in Northside over here on Overbrook Road, and it was just about maybe eight or ten blocks from Chandler.
And then after high school, you went on to...
I went to Howard University.
And that was an interesting time too, in the late 60s, because I had a bit of political activity and black power and African history and all these things that were still there.
That were starting to emerge.
And so, you know, for me, it was kind of a high opening time.
I was fortunate to have, for example, a history class with one of the imminent scholars on African history.
Whose name just went out of my head, but I think I would have had a minute.
But I had never heard anything about Africa up until that time, other than Tarzan movies, but nothing in terms of any kind of African civilizations or any of that kind of thing.
So that was eye-opening. And of course, there were a lot of, you know, black revolutionaries on campus, Stokely Carmichael and H.R.F. Brown, the idea of black power.
So there was definitely a change starting to happen then from Martin Luther King, non-violent protest, kind of passive protest, the idea of integration to the idea of...
You know, kind of black nationalism kind of thing among the black intellectuals at Howard.
And where was your mind then?
My mind was, you know, I was kind of persuaded by that argument.
I mean, most of it was kind of just rebellion of what I was familiar with.
Didn't want to be a black bourgeoisie anymore.
So, you know, that might have held sway for a year or two, but...
Gradually, I mean, I'm thinking of kind of moving in other directions.
This is when I first started to get interested in Eastern philosophy and meditation and things like that.
And I think that was kind of a, you know, I can see it as a continuum of my experience as a child growing up in the segregated south, that you really have to do a lot of introspection and...
You have to really think about your sense of self in terms of, you know, these people don't like me because of skin color.
And it causes, you know, a lot of those kinds of self-increased occur.
And that continued and eventually in college, it took a more inward turn.
And I found that some of these books in the Indian philosophy really spoke to me.
I wasn't... I was a history major, but as a senior, I took a course in perception in psychology.
And that also had a big influence on me, the idea that in many ways we construct reality, you know, based on our expectancies and our beliefs and our previous experiences.
So that's, you know, it was too late to change my major then, but I did go into psychology and graduate school.
But in between graduating from university and going to grad school, I studied meditation more and became a meditation teacher first in Boston and then Detroit.
And that's, I got to University of Michigan.
It's interesting to think about it. And you're really putting that together, the idea, you know, I often think about in practicing the strategy of non-violence in particular or just handling one's self with dignity and trying to be non-reactive or thoughtful about one's reaction.
That's really is a process of mindfulness.
Yeah, it is.
And you were really, you were already thinking in those terms back then.
By the time I got to college, yeah.
Well, by the time I started, this was kind of late in my college career, I started discovering Indian philosophy.
I kind of, you know, heard about Gandhi and knew he had some influence on King, but I really didn't know that much about Gandhi's story or...
Well, other aspects of Indian philosophy or hemsa, what, you know, what that meant.
Were there others at Howard that were getting into this or were you considered an apple?
I was pretty out there by myself.
I mean, meditation is very mainstream these days.
But not in those days.
Yeah, not so much.
There you go.
So then on to Michigan, you said?
Yeah.
There was one other point I wanted to make though about my early years.
When I was in those segregated schools in Richmond growing up, the quality of the teachers was just amazing.
I mean, there were some kind of unintended consequences of integration.
I think one of the losses was the quality of the black teachers that we had in those classrooms.
Women for the most part.
And so again, this is another kind of confluence of things, but you know, the women's movement was very big in the 60s also.
And so at one time, all the best and brightest women went into teaching.
And so now they had wider possibilities.
And we didn't really put anything in place to attract the best and brightest into education anymore.
And I think black education has suffered more than education in general because of these other influence of white,
white, tax-based, erosion, poor resources in the inner cities.
I mean, I now work a lot with Petersburg.
And they have the lowest performing schools in the state.
It's kind of a desperate situation.
They lost their tax-based number of years ago and tobacco companies moved out.
I just saw yesterday they get ready to lose a chemical plant too.
But when you have a school district like that, it becomes this spiraling kind of downward pattern.
Because even if you get some decent teachers, they immediately get recruited away.
Because they can make more money at surrounding districts and have half the headaches.
And so it becomes very difficult to recruit people into those kinds of school districts and administrators.
Since I started working with the schools in 2005 and they've been four superintendents in that time in Petersburg.
Was there something lost to you think when the schools desegregated with the talk about administrators,
the black principals and some of the black teachers that had been working in a black school system and as things change, and what happens to them?
Yeah. And most of the principals were not given principalships again when things integrated.
The teachers, I mean, for one thing, most of the black educators during the era of segregation kind of saw themselves on a mission.
The education was the key for upward mobility and that would be driven in.
And again, you didn't have this kind of class segregation that we have now in the black schools.
Because kids from middle class, lower middle class, everybody was there in the same school.
And so there was a sense of kind of shared values and things that we get inculcated.
Whereas now, you know, the black middle classes out in the suburbs with the white middle class.
So in the inner city, you mainly have, you know, kind of these hubs of poverty and, you know, lack of role models, lack of resources.
So now it becomes sort of, those are different people entirely and that's their problem in front of the point of view of those in the summer.
And again, it still has a strong racial component to that, but you do have class kind of overlaying with that as well.
And is that in the case here in Richmond?
Oh, definitely.
I mean, I think that's one of the main things holding Richmond back is this lack of cooperation between the city and the surrounding counties.
And, you know, if you talk to the leaders in the counties, none of them would say race has anything to do with it these days.
But the seeds of this were definitely in the racial politics, you know, even though it's morphed into other things these days.
How has Richmond recognized its change in the legacy of the movement and has Richmond recognized your father's contribution?
Yeah, Richmond has.
We had a succession of governors that have attempted to, you know, kind of add the black story to Virginia history.
There was another thing that was interesting when I first went to white schools and we would take a Virginia history class.
And when you read about slavery, it was such a benign institution, you know, they were just like family members, you know, everybody loved everybody.
Even from my brief experience, knew that was a lot of crap.
That was what was being taught.
And so you can understand why, you know, the larger white community doesn't understand what the problem is or why we still talking about slavery 150 years later.
So I forgot your question, but...
If Virginia and Richmond in particular have tried to correct things in some way or at least made a, you know, a semblance of trying to, and have they recognized the movement and your father?
I think, you know, this started with the election of Doug Wilder and you had George Allen in there, but there's been a succession of democratic governors who have attempted to do this.
And they were able to acknowledge the black contribution to Virginia history and particularly the civil rights history.
In the 40s and 50s and 60s, more cases, civil rights cases were brought in Richmond, I mean, in Virginia than any other southern state.
And...
What is that? I mean...
The father of Mr. Robinson.
Well, yeah, I guess they were just kind of active, but, you know, there was kind of a climate here.
There was a willingness to make that sacrifice among the populace.
And probably it might have been that Virginia, you know, for all of his problems was never Mississippi, you know.
I mean, even though we had lynchings here and we had problems, and again, Barbara Johns got run out of Farm Bill, you didn't have that constant kind of balance that you had further in the south.
So maybe that created a climate where people felt a little safer to come forward and stand up against some of these segregation laws.
That's the possibility.
So more monuments and things like that began to appear on the landscape to recognize that there was more than civil war generals.
Right.
Well, first it was the Arthur Ashe statue on monument avenue and that caused a big uproar.
Can briefly, can you tell us a little bit about, you know, just for the record, because I think it's an interesting story.
The monument avenue, what monuments were there.
Well, monument avenue was an avenue of monuments to Confederate generals and for the most part.
And so you have, and the statues, you know, are huge statues, particularly of Robert E. Lee.
The statues be facing a certain direction. They were facing the south if they survived the war. They're facing north if they were killed in the war.
So it's a very stately street.
And so then the proposal came to erect a statue to Arthur Ashe and it was decided by the city council to put it on monument avenue.
And of course, a lot of people came out of the woodwork complaining about this, that was kind of a sacrilege.
I mean, it's so interesting. And I think one of the reasons Virginia is changing is because kind of the old Gentile Virginia, which was never as overtly racist as people further south.
But it was still re-retired every now and then with these kind of things.
I mean, there was a big objection to putting a statue of Lincoln at the Trediger Ironworks, which was a building left over from the Civil War.
But, and this was like 10 years ago, 15 years ago.
And it was an objection to a statue of Lincoln, you know, these days. It's just unbelievable.
But as heritage not hate you.
Well, I wouldn't be in Virginia, too. And especially in Southwest Virginia, it can be pretty wacky sometimes.
People are really still playing a little violent in about the war.
Yeah, I mean, it's the war that never ends. In the South where rise again.
Okay.
So as a kid going downtown, these were the figures that towered over you.
And then Ashe was added and others.
Well, others yet on monument avenue. But they did put in this memorial to Virginia Civil Rights history on the Capitol grounds, which pictures Barbara Johns on one side and my father and Robinson on one side.
And it's just an acknowledgement of Virginia's role in the Civil Rights movement.
And of course, it's right down from a statue of Harry Bird. It's an interesting juxtaposition.
And also they named a building from my father on the Capitol grounds, the old finance building.
And there's an irony about that, too, because that was the place where Bird and some of the others kind of worked out their initial strategy for massive resistance.
And it was also a building where when my father graduated from law school, he went there to take the bar exam.
And of course, the seating was segregated and he came in late. And the only city saw was up front, which was in the white section. So he wouldn't sit down there.
And it was a bit of a ral, but I think they eventually let him sit there.
And so all that's in that same building.
But seeing his name on it must people don't know those back stories.
And nationally, how has your father and his work been recognized?
Well, in the last 10 years of his life, he lived to be a hundred. And so the last 10 years of his life, he did get a lot of national recognition, which was good.
And he was able to get that before he died. And in 1999, President Clinton gave him the presidential medal of freedom, which was the highest civilian honor.
Is it in the middle there?
Yes.
Is it possible to get a shot of the...
Okay, we're going over for a shot.
This will take a little... I'm just going to let the camera run and do it.
So that's the presidential medal of freedom that was awarded in 2009.
That's now you know.
And is that your father's foster?
Yes.
Okay.
Is this getting a second to get a shot of that?
Just want to make sure we have a shot of that.
That would bring in if need be.
That's great.
Okay, I think we can keep going.
Okay.
So I want to shift to asking you about your career in psychology and how some of these concerns interest themes may have played into your work.
Yeah.
Well, my whole career has been at Virginia State University, which is a historically black university.
So, you know, just kind of being in that environment, you reminded of all of this history.
Because Virginia State and most of the other HBCUs were founded to provide an opportunity for blacks and states to have a higher education.
They didn't want them to come to the white institutions.
And you know, our colors are orange and blue because we used to get hand me downs from UVA for football, other things.
I didn't know that.
That was why.
Interesting.
And, you know, over the years, it's been interesting to see the politics around, you know, state allocations for our education with VSU.
In Virginia, you know, we have a system unlike many states.
I mean, North Carolina, you have one state system in Virginia.
We have tech and UVA.
And then we have, kind of a second tier now, VCU in George Mason, maybe, and then the rest of us.
But, you know, so just being in that setting, you know, just kind of creates a lot of reminders of those kinds of things.
And a lot of my research has been done on black education and cognitive factors.
And it's been interesting, you know, looking at this thing about US education and, you know, thinking from brown forward,
how the current state is really the latest iteration of those same issues that was there 50 or 60 years ago.
And now, of course, we know about the effect of nutrition on education and our early childhood medical attention and cognitive stimulation.
One of the things that is definitely a key element of the lagging of black educational achievement nationwide is this lack of early childhood stimulation.
But we know now that these cognitive abilities that in the 50s were thought to be totally fixed all heredity.
We know they're malleable and that with the right kinds of experiences, you can start to develop these skills.
That's been something that I've been interested in working with the last 10 or 15 years or so.
And that's how I got first in contact with the Aldrich Project and Bob Moses.
We set up a project in Petersburg and they came in.
Bob Moses was an early civil rights leader in the 1960s and he's involved in a lot of the voter registration programs, things that went on in Mississippi.
And then he later got a PhD in math from Harvard and he was dissatisfied with the way in which his own kids were experiencing math in Cambridge schools.
So he developed these approaches to teaching abstract mathematical concepts in ways that are based on experiences, the life experiences of children.
And he's been very successful in doing that.
But he also takes a civil rights approach to school reform in that he uses the same kind of principles of community organization around support for schools.
That it's not just the schools or the teachers by themselves that can bring about change, but it takes a whole community effort.
Can bring in the parents and the community.
Exactly.
So that's been very interesting.
And that connects back to your experience, the way that you read about slavery, what you said before, the kinds of materials that are presented to students.
We did an interview with a woman in California, Miljard Pitt's Walter, who was an educator in the Los Angeles system in the 40s and 50s.
She was looking for story books with black kids in them to teach the black kids in her class and there were no such things.
So she wrote her own.
And made it into a career.
But it's interesting that kind of thing.
So what kind of effects can that have?
Can you measure and see a change when you do introduce materials like that?
Yes, you can.
One of the things that we're always looking for is transfer.
If you work in the cognitive domain and you're trying to develop cognitive skills per se, through practice of things like attention and short-term memory and those kinds of activities, do you get transfer to performance in math or other things?
We find that you do.
You do need content as well, but it's like the cognitive training is like building the framework.
And then you still need the content to fit into that framework.
But without the framework, there's nothing for the content to adhere to.
And so students in general today tend to, you know, even high-performing students tend to have all these unorganized concepts that aren't integrated in any kind of way.
Aren't able to do any kind of abstraction from those concepts.
And a lot of it is from the lack of that development of underlying cognitive framework.
And, you know, in general, there's kind of been a dumbing down of education in the country over the years.
When I went to Chandler when I was 12 or 13, I mean, this might seem just being apparent reality because of my advancing age.
But it seems as if the educational rigor was higher than it is with college kids these days.
And in terms of both the breadth and the depth of information that we were exposed to.
And I think part of that is in terms of the teacher pool, I think part of it is in terms of educational experience.
I think part of it is some unintended consequences from well-meaning liberal teachers who didn't have the right level of expectation for black students.
My mother was an educator for years.
I can remember her saying that in the 60s when they started to have the integrated schools that these teachers weren't holding the kids to the same stand as the black teachers were holding the kids to.
And so there was this, I mean, George Bush, you know, I don't agree with him on very many things.
When he came up with one phrase I thought was pretty apt and that was, and I can't remember the phrase now, but it was something about the high prejudices of low expectations or something like that.
And I think that's true that, you know, the self-esteem movement and the social passing movement, I don't know if you can call them movements, but it tends to be trends in education.
I think I've done a lot of damage and I think a lot of that came from well-meaning people worried about the ability of these poor little black kids in a city and what they couldn't could not do.
And most of the studies you read about minority education that works instead of dumbing down a curriculum to remediate any lacking information,
is producing a challenging curriculum, you know, producing something that's going to stretch their capabilities.
And students tend to respond to expectations.
But how challenging is that, especially in state of Virginia, and given our ironically named SOLs, our standards of learning,
to really affect change in both the curriculum and in the pedagogy?
It's extremely challenging and that's been one of the problems with a school district like Petersburg.
It's hard to come in and try to institute some innovation when everything is about the test scores.
And you know, when the curriculum is so drained of any kind of intellectually stimulating content is all about performance on the test.
And I think the lower performing schools disproportionately affects them in terms of how they spend their resources and their time.
I know that whoever is going to be watching this doesn't want to hear me, but this conversation is something that I'm passionate about as an educator in the Virginia Tech College system, or in the Virginia College system at Virginia Tech,
we work really closely with the local high school students and we've been trying a lot to bring in African American history, civil rights history, did a whole teaching on over to Washington and well people.
The teachers are hungry for it, but we hear again and again, how am I going to teach it?
How will affect the SOLs?
There's nothing to make it exciting, it's just the drudgery that you've memorized.
Very great drudgery is.
So they're frustrated and they willingly come to these teacher workshops. They have very few days or time off and they take that time to learn more.
And then the last question at the end of the day is always, so this was great for me. How can I carve out an hour of a lesson plan?
It's true.
So it's probably going to take some kind of radical restructuring of education.
The old industrial age model, factory model of schools is probably, past day now, we need to come up with some new approach in general.
That one size fits all kind of thing.
Okay.
Well, where else would you like to take this?
I wonder if there's anything related to this that you'd like to speak about or reflecting back?
I see anything we haven't covered.
I guess the only thing additionally I would like to say is just that I am optimistic.
I do think that we will rebound from all of this. It'll just be relatively slow.
But we do need to, you know, we're starting to see a little bit of a movement toward innovation and education.
Even though it's an entrenched kind of bureaucracy, it's going to be slow to change.
I think change is inevitable, both for K through 12 education and higher education.
The university, as we know it now, probably is not going to exist for that much longer.
The explosion of online courses and MOOCs and whatever the next innovation is going to be.
Well, not really the challenges of what education is all about.
For me, it was a few inspiring teachers.
It didn't matter what they were teaching. It was an example of their person.
I wanted to be a software or two new boards on the guitar.
I can go to my computer. But that's not the same as working with someone.
It's true.
That was one of the things that I think has been the biggest change from teachers
when I was growing up to teach Dessie now is the excitement about the knowledge and being able to pass on that excitement.
It definitely wasn't a wrote and it wasn't something that was just for performance on a test.
But they would excite you about the ideas and excite you about the concepts.
So where do you put that insight then into the civil rights, you know, the big picture of the civil rights movement.
I mean, there was a lot of focus, I think, rightly so.
You probably agree on changing the school system as it was.
So, but what does that mean as to, are we still fighting?
I don't know how to do that.
In a way, we are still fighting the same battle.
It's just changed its form a little bit.
So instead of racial segregation, now we have class segregation.
I think the state of our school, particularly in the city schools, is a national disgrace.
And the fact that we've allowed this to happen.
And then we allow students to go to schools in conditions that are just deplorable.
We talk about having education as a high priority, but we don't put the action behind that.
And we always find the money for whatever, you know, we feel as a necessity.
Somehow we found a trillion dollars to fight a war in Iraq.
There was off the book, so to speak.
If we put those kind of resources into education, it's just...
And we find scholarships for athletes.
But not always for those who are merit-based.
But I do think that education a day is kind of the legacy of the civil rights struggle of the last few years.
And I think this is where the battlegrounds of the speak of the continuing struggle is going to be.
And that we have to not only get the political will, but the popular awareness of the need for change.
And it's interesting, a lot of the organizations who were the main movers and shakers in the civil rights era need to change their approach and change their tactics.
Now we mobilize when somebody uses the inward or a national outrage.
Where's the outrage over the conditions that these kids are going to school in?
We need that kind of leadership in direction.
I mean, outrage over the disproportionate number of Black community in prison.
Yes. And I think all these things are related.
There's an industrial complex and the war on drugs.
It's definitely related to the collapsing family structures and the educational system in inner cities.
So it's like all these things are part of the mix.
And we all know that interesting book about the new Jim Crow is about the prison system.
I thought that was a perfect summation.
The end.
Trained in courtrooms, as a young child.
Anything else you want to add? This has been terrific.
No, I think so.
Great.
I'm good.
I want to thank you so much.
I still have two hours left on.
We could go.
Should the prison.
No, that was fantastic.
Thank you, Robert.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.